I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
我50岁了，你知道我度假时最不想做的事情是什么吗？哦，大概有那么几件。我不想把我们一家老小挤进同一间只有一间卧室和一个卫生间的房间里。我不想。不。我不想让我们所有人都挤在一起。我想有我自己的卧室，和孩子们分开，这就是为什么我更喜欢Airbnb。因为我们都可以拥有各自的空间，然后，这就让整个假期变得更轻松。我们可以不同时间睡觉。你知道的，我可以熬夜看书，
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
或者现在的更有可能的情况是，我在其他人之前就上床睡觉了。你知道我最喜欢Airbnb的什么吗？什么？零食。你知道我最喜欢Airbnb的什么吗？什么？零食。你有一个冰箱，你有一个厨房。所以我不用一直打电话叫客房服务还得付那笔费用。
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks, they're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. Hey, Spotify, This is Javi. My biggest passion is music. And it's not just sounds and instruments. It's more than that to me.
我只会觉得，嘿，我们带了零食，它们都在冰箱里，去拿吧。好了，各位，为你们的下一次冒险考虑一下Airbnb吧。改住民宿，绝对是你不会后悔的选择。嘿，Spotify，我是哈维（Javi）。我最大的激情是音乐。它不仅仅是声音和乐器。对我来说，这意义更重大。
It's a world full of harmonies with chillers. From streaming to shopping, it's on Prime. Hello, and welcome to your second drink of The Client. I want my baby back, baby back, baby back. Yep. And threat level midnight. We got really fun insights from both Tim Meadows and Melora Hardin for this breakdown.
这是一个充满和声的世界，让人放松。从流媒体到购物，亚马逊Prime应有尽有。你好，欢迎收看你的第二杯《客户》。我想要回我的肋排，肋排，肋排。没错。还有午夜威胁级别。对于这次深度解析，蒂姆·梅多斯（Tim Meadows）和梅洛拉·哈丁（Melora Hardin）都给我们分享了非常有趣的见解。
Yes. But we did uncover a few more details we can share. First off, at the very beginning of the episode, everyone is gathered in the kitchen talking about their worst dates. Yes. And this is Pam's famous story about being left behind at a minor league hockey game.
是的。但我们确实还发掘出了一些可以分享的更多细节。首先，在这一集的开头，大家都聚集在厨房里谈论他们最糟糕的约会。是的。这就是潘（Pam）那个著名的故事：在小联盟冰球比赛中被抛弃。
Lady, any time I post a photo of myself at a hockey game, people just say, I hope you didn't get left behind. I bet the first time you're like, what's going on? I did, because I had forgotten. But yes. Well, there is a deleted scene where Jim reveals his worst first date. You got to hear it.
天哪，每当我发布一张自己在冰球比赛现场的照片时，人们就会说：“希望你没有被抛弃。”我敢打赌，第一次听到的时候你会想：“这到底是怎么回事？”我确实被抛弃了，因为我把这事给忘了。但对。不过，有一个被删减的片段，吉姆（Jim）在里面透露了他最糟糕的初次约会。你得听听这个。
What was my worst first date? It was a couple of years ago. It was a lunch date, actually. It was right down here at Caginos. And we had just met, and we really hit it off. It was kind of nice. And then as it turned out, it wasn't even a date because she was actually in love with someone else.
我最糟糕的初次约会是什么时候？那是几年前的事了。其实那是一次午餐约会。就在这下面的卡吉诺斯餐厅（Caginos）。我们刚认识，而且真的很合得来。感觉还挺不错的。然后结果证明，这根本算不上约会，因为她其实爱着别人。
So best first dates also my worst first date, oddly enough. What is happening? He's talking about Pam. Yes. Right. He clearly asked Pam out for lunch when they first started working together and didn't know about Roy and slowly during this lunch found out she was dating. Yeah. My gosh. I know. Aw, poor Jim. Well, we also got some fan mail about a moment that we missed in our breakdown, and it is a good one. At four minutes, Michael is walking out of the office with Jan.
所以这既是我最好的初次约会，也是我最糟糕的初次约会，说来也怪。这到底是怎么回事？他在说潘。是的。没错。很显然，当他们刚开始一起工作时，他约了潘共进午餐，当时并不知道罗伊（Roy）的存在，然后在这次午餐期间慢慢发现她在和别人交往。是啊。天哪。我知道。哦，可怜的吉姆。对了，我们还收到了一封粉丝邮件，提到我们在解析中漏掉的一个精彩瞬间，这个片段真的很棒。在第四分钟时，迈克尔（Michael）正和简（Jan）一起走出办公室。
He's on his way to his meeting, and the camera swings over to Oscar in accounting. And you can see that he's talking to someone. You don't see the person completely. It's mostly just the top of their head, but it is clearly Devin. Wait, Devin's been fired. Yes, he was fired two episodes ago in Halloween. And that is because we shot the client
他正要去开会，镜头一转，切到了会计部的奥斯卡（Oscar）。你可以看到他正在和某人说话。你看不到那个人的全貌。大部分只能看到他们的头顶，但这显然是德文（Devin）。等等，德文不是被解雇了吗？是的，他在两集前的《万圣节》里被解雇了。那是因为我们拍摄《客户》
before we shot Halloween. Oh. In fact, here's how we shot the episodes. We shot the client, Halloween, the fight, but then we released them, Halloween, the fight, the episodes. We shot the client, Halloween, the fight, but then we released them Halloween, the fight, the client. So that's how Devin sneaked into the background of this episode. That's a good catch.
是在拍摄《万圣节》之前。哦。事实上，我们拍摄这些剧集的顺序是这样的：我们拍了《客户》、《万圣节》、《打架》，但随后我们播出的顺序是：《万圣节》、《打架》、《客户》。所以这就是为什么德文会潜入这一集的背景中。这是一个很好的发现。
All right. Well, next up, I have a tidbit for the scene where Michael calls Pam on the phone and he wants her to read him some jokes from his joke book. We talked about this a little bit the first time, but I have more to share. But first, let's listen to it. Dunder Mifflin, this is Pam. Pam, it's Michael. I need you to go into my office and check some data for me. Okay. You want me to read them? Yes. Okay. A fisherman is walking down Fifth Avenue leading an animal behind him. No, no. Told it. Not as good as you think. Pick another one. Okay. There's a transcript between a naval ship.
好了。那么接下来，我有一个关于某个场景的花絮：迈克尔给潘打电话，想要她从他的笑话书里读几个笑话给他听。我们第一次聊到这个时稍微提过一点，但我还有更多要分享的。不过首先，我们来听听这段音频。邓德米夫林，我是潘。潘，我是迈克尔。我需要你进我办公室帮我核对一些数据。好的。你想让我读出来吗？是的。好的。一个渔夫正走在第五大道上，身后牵着一只动物。不，不。这个讲过了。没有你想的那么好。换一个。好的。有一段关于一艘海军舰艇的对话记录……
Okay. Bingo. And a lighthouse. Yes, that is his heracle. Could you start that one from the beginning? All right. So when we broke down this episode, I said that none of the jokes had any endings, that they were just the beginning. But this joke does have an ending. This is a very famous joke about a naval ship and a lighthouse. Although as soon as you say lighthouse, you kind of ruin the joke. But here it is.
好的。太棒了。和一个灯塔的对话。是的，这就是他的笑话。你能从头开始读那个吗？好的，所以当我们剖析这一集的时候，我说过这些笑话都没有结尾，它们都只有开头。但这个笑话确实是有结尾的。这是一个非常著名的关于海军舰艇和灯塔的笑话。尽管只要你一说出灯塔，你其实就把这个笑话给剧透了。不过，内容是这样的：
I'm going to tell you the joke. The joke is it's a transcript. The naval ship says, please divert your course 0.5 degrees to the south to avoid a collision. The response is, recommend response is, The response is, The response is, The response is, The response is,
我要把这个笑话讲给你听。这个笑话是一段对话记录。海军舰艇说：“请将你的航向向南调整0.5度以避免碰撞。”回应是，建议的回应是，回应是，回应是，回应是，回应是，
The response is, The response is, The response is, The response is, The response is, The response is, The response is, The reply is, no, I say again, you divert your course. So the ship says, this is the aircraft carrier USS Coral Sea.
回应是，回应是，回应是，回应是，回应是，回应是，回应是，答复是，不，我再说一遍，请你调整航向。于是这艘舰艇说：“这是美国海军‘罗斯福海号’航空母舰。
We are a large warship of the US Navy. Divert your course now. And the reply is, this is a lighthouse. Your call. That's the joke. That's a good one. But since we are talking about jokes, I thought maybe we could go around and each share one of our most favorite clean go-to jokes.
我们是美国海军的一艘大型军舰。请立刻调整你的航向。”而答复则是：“这是一座灯塔。你自己看着办吧。”这就是那个笑话。这个不错。不过既然我们在聊笑话，我想也许我们可以轮流分享一个我们最喜欢的健康得体的常用笑话。
Okay. Why didn't the baker buy a new car? Why? He didn't have enough dough. Oh, Angela knew it. I didn't. I just guessed. Cassie?
好的。为什么面包师不买新车？为什么？因为他面团（钱）不够。哦，安吉拉（Angela）猜到了。我没有。我只是瞎猜的。卡西（Cassie）？
Which baseball player wears the biggest helmet? I don't know. The one with the biggest head. Oh! All right, so this is just one of Josh's favorite dad jokes. So I thought I had to tell it because he does it all the time and the kids kids walk right into
哪个棒球运动员戴的头盔最大？我不知道。头最大的那个。哦！好吧，这其实只是乔希（Josh）最喜欢的冷笑话之一。所以我觉得我必须讲出来，因为他总是这么说，而孩子们每次都会
it every time. So let's say we're at the grocery store and it's like during the holidays, it's like a busy time. He'll say, oh man, this grocery store is like camping. And they'll be like, why? And he says, it's intense. Yeah, I know, Sam. I know.
毫不犹豫地掉进这个坑里。所以假设我们在杂货店，而且正赶上假期，那是一个很忙碌的时候。他会说：“哦天哪，这家店就像在野营。”然后他们会问：“为什么？”而他说：“因为这很紧张刺激（intense也有‘扎营’的意思）。”是的，我知道，萨姆。我知道。
I know. He does know. I know. He does it all the time. He'll be like, we're driving. And he'll be like, this freeway is like camping. They're like, why? It's intense. I'm clenching my fists. I know.
我知道。他确实知道。我知道。他总是这样。我们会说：“我们在开车。”然后他就会说：“这条高速公路就像野营。”他们会问：“为什么？”“因为它很紧张刺激。”我在握紧拳头。我知道。
It's endless. Well, Ange, it's funny. I'm going to share Lee's favorite joke. OK. OK. A grasshopper walks into a bar, goes up to the bartender. The bartender says, oh my gosh, we have a drink named after you. And he says, you have a drink named Bill?
没完没了了。好吧，安吉，真有意思。我要分享莉（Lee）最喜欢的笑话。好的。好的。一只蚱蜢走进一家酒吧，走到酒保面前。酒保说：“哦天哪，我们有一款以你名字命名的酒。”它说：“你们有一款叫比尔（Bill）的酒吗？”
Thank you, Sam. That's very cute. Thank you. That's very cute. That's very cute. Our kids like that one. Okay. Well, next up in our second drink tidbit, at seven minutes and 57 seconds, Michael starts singing the Baby Back Ribs song.
谢谢你，萨姆。这太可爱了。谢谢。这太可爱了。这太可爱了。我们的孩子们挺喜欢这个的。好的。那么，在我们的“第二杯”花絮中，接下来在7分57秒处，迈克尔开始唱起“肋排之歌”。
And we talked about this in our breakdown, how they could not keep it together, but I thought we could play the blooper because it is so funny. I want my baby back, baby back, baby back, baby back. I want my baby back, baby back, baby back, baby back. I want my baby back. Chili's baby back rib.
我们在解析中讨论过，他们当时是如何笑场到无法继续的，但我想我们可以播放这段NG花絮，因为它真的太搞笑了。我想要回我的肋排，肋排，肋排，肋排。我想要回我的肋排，肋排，肋排，肋排。我想要回我的肋排。奇利斯（Chili's）餐厅的肋排。
That's the best. I know. I want my baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back baby back ribs. No, wait out the second one. Okay. Clearly, clearly when Steve goes into the chili, that was it. That's all they had in them. They couldn't make it through. Well, final tidbit everyone,
这绝对是最好的。我知道。我想要回我的肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排肋排这样。不，等等，重新来第二个。好的。很显然，很显然当史蒂夫走进奇利斯餐厅时，那就是全部了。他们当时就只有这些素材。他们根本没法顺利拍完。好了，最后一条花絮，各位，
I'm calling this prop trick of the trade. At nine minutes and 40 seconds, Dwight has a talking head in the kitchen and there is a can of wet ones by the sink. They are clearly the brand wet ones, but they have whited out the T in wet and the O in ones, so it actually says weenus. Everybody, this is a prop trick of the trade. They do this on sets to obscure a label or a logo. That way they don't have to make a fake one or a blank one. COLLEEN O'BRIEN Or pay for the company, like product placement.
我把这个叫做“道具行业小诀窍”。在9分40秒的时候，德怀特（Dwight）在厨房里有一段面对镜头的独白，水槽边上放着一罐湿纸巾（Wet Ones）。它们明显是Wet Ones这个牌子的，但他们把“Wet”里的字母“T”和“Ones”里的字母“O”用白色涂改液涂掉了，所以它实际上拼出来变成了“weenus”（意思是阴茎皮或肘部松弛的皮肤）。各位，这就是道具行业的小诀窍。他们在片场会这样做来掩盖标签或徽标。这样他们就不必特意制作一个假的或者空白的标签了。科琳·奥布赖恩 或者是为了避免替公司打广告，比如植入性广告。
RISA GOLUBOFF Yes. I noticed they also put a cozy on the hand soap to hide its label, and they put a tape over the dish soap label as well. COLLEEN O'BRIEN Well, there you go, you guys. That was our second drink of the client. Yeah. Whoa. It's amazing. It's so fun.
瑞莎·戈卢博夫 是的。我注意到他们还在洗手液瓶上套了一个套子来遮住它的标签，而且他们也在洗洁精的标签上贴了一段胶带。科琳·奥布赖恩 好啦，各位，这就是我们这期关于《客户》的第二杯节目。耶。哇。太神奇了。太有趣了。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories
我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并送上独家的幕后故事，这些故事只有两个当时身处其中……专门为你制作。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并送上独家的幕后故事，
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Season two, episode seven, The Client. The Client. Welcome to Office Ladies everyone. I am still putting my note cards on the table. This is more note cards than I've ever seen you have ever. Jenna I take my job very seriously. I am keeper of the note cards, first of her name. It's Keeper Thrones Jenna. I'm keeper of the note
只有两个当时身处其中亲历这一切的人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室女士》。第二季第七集，《客户》。《客户》。欢迎来到《办公室女士》，各位。我还在把我的便签卡摆在桌上。这比我见过的你用过的便签卡还要多。珍娜，我对我的工作非常认真。我是便签卡守护者，她名字的第一位。这是《权力的游戏》，珍娜。我是便签卡的
cards. Angela you know I don't know that show. Well I'm gonna quote it at you for the rest of my life. You do quote it at me. Okay where are we at? Let's get started. This episode was written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Greg Daniels. You have nothing to say to that? You don't have, you've got a gazillion note cards, but nothing to say to that. No, I mean, listen, sometimes you say things
守护者。安吉拉，你知道我没看过那个节目。好吧，我会在接下来的余生里一直拿它来向你疯狂玩梗的。你确实一直拿它玩梗。好了，我们进行到哪了？开始吧。这一集由保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）导演。对此你没什么要说的吗？你难道没有……你有一大堆便签卡，但对此却无话可说？不，我的意思是，听着，有时你说的那些
that are just facts. That's just a fact. I don't know what to do with that. So like, yes, that is true, Jenna. That is a true statement. That is who wrote this and who directed this. Next. Okay. Well, I guess next, I usually do a summary. Yeah. But I'm not going to do it today. Why? Because I don't maybe like, I don't like that you're not responding to me today. No, I'm kidding.
都只是事实。那纯粹就是事实。对此我不知道该作何反应。所以，是的，那是真的，珍娜。那是一个事实陈述。这就是本集的编剧和导演。下一个。好吧。好吧，我想接下来，我通常会做个总结。对。但我今天不打算做了。为什么？因为我可能……我不喜欢你今天不搭理我。不，我开玩笑的。
But I'm not gonna do the summary today because I got someone else to do the summary. Who? I don't know, somebody. Is it your husband Lee? It's not my husband Lee. I'm gonna let you listen. All right, hit play, Sam.
但我今天不做总结了，因为我找了别人来做总结。谁？不知道，随便什么人。是你丈夫李（Lee）吗？不是我丈夫李。我这就放给你听。好了，点击播放，萨姆。
In the client, Michael heads to Chili's with Jam to try and close a deal with a major client. While Michael is gone, Pam discovers a screenplay Michael has been writing called Threat Level Midnight, an action movie about an FBI agent named Michael Scarn, who is married to yours truly, Catherine Zeta-Jones. The staff divides up the roles and reads the script aloud. Also in this episode, Jim and Pam share grilled cheese sandwiches on the rooftop of Dunder Mifflin and Michael and Jan share a kiss.
在《客户》中，迈克尔和简前往奇利斯餐厅，试图与一个重要客户达成交易。迈克尔走后，潘发现了一部迈克尔一直在写的名为《午夜威胁级别》的剧本，这是一部动作电影，讲述了一名叫迈克尔·斯坎的FBI特工的故事，他娶了如假包换的凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯（Catherine Zeta-Jones）。员工们瓜分了角色并大声朗读了剧本。同样在本集中，吉姆和潘在邓德米夫林的屋顶上分享了烤奶酪三明治，迈克尔和简分享了一个吻。
Oh my god! Holy crap, balls! Is that Catherine Zeta Jones? That is Catherine Zeta Jones. You are freaking kidding me! I'm not! I'm not. What the hell? What the hell? You what, I mean, what is going on? Yes, should I explain? Yeah.
哦天哪！我的妈呀！那是凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯吗？那是凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯。你在开什么国际玩笑！我没开玩笑！我真的没开玩笑。搞什么鬼？搞什么鬼？你，我的意思是，这到底是怎么回事？是的，需要我解释一下吗？好啊。
Yeah? All right, I've never met her. I should start with that. Wait, what? Did you not know that? We've never met. No, I didn't know that. In my mind, you're like, you have this whole friendship with like a big movie star and
真的吗？好吧，我从来没见过她。我应该从这说起。等等，什么？你不知道这件事吗？我们从来没见过面。不，我不知道。在我脑海里，你会觉得，你和某个大电影明星之间有种深厚的友谊，然后
I'm like, oh, that's cool, Jenna, I guess, whatever. Well, I'd like to say I would love to be friends with her. She has a love of movie musicals, like traditional movie musicals. She's so good herself. She's so fantastic. But I also have that love. So I have daydreams of us watching like old movie musicals together and then tap dancing a little bit and then maybe having a cocktail or some tea.
我会觉得，“哦，那挺酷的，珍娜，我想吧，随便啦。”好吧，我想说的是，我很乐意和她做朋友。她对音乐电影有着极大的热爱，尤其是传统的音乐电影。她自己就很擅长这个。她太棒了。但我也同样热爱音乐电影。所以我常常幻想着我们一起看老电影音乐剧，然后一起跳一点踢踏舞，接着也许喝上一杯鸡尾酒或喝点茶。
Reenacting scenes from Chicago. Yeah, this is what I imagine my friendship with Catherine Zeta Jones is like. But I did do a movie with Michael Douglas. I played his daughter in a movie called Solitary Man. He's so good in it. It stars him and Jesse Eisenberg. In that movie, I did my first New York City walk and talk.
重现《芝加哥》里的场景。对，这就是我脑海中想象我和凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯的友谊。不过我确实和迈克尔·道格拉斯（Michael Douglas）合作过一部电影。我在一部叫《孤独的人》（Solitary Man）的电影里演他的女儿。他在里面演得太棒了。主演还有他和杰西·艾森伯格（Jesse Eisenberg）。在那部电影里，我在纽约街头完成了我的第一次“边走边聊”。
Do you know those movies you see that are shot in New York and they're just people that are just walking and talking? And from the time I was little, I would see this in movies. And that to me was like, you're a movie star. Doing a walk and talk. If you do a walk and talk on the streets of New York, you've made it kid. So I'm shooting this scene with Michael Douglas and I turned to him and I said, Michael, this is my first New York City walk and talk. And he turned to me, he got it. He goes, what? You got to be kidding me.
你知道你在电影里看到的那些在纽约拍摄的镜头吗？就是人们一边走路一边聊天。从我很小的时候起，我就在电影里看到过这种场景。对我来说，这就意味着：“你成大明星了。”拍一场“边走边聊”的戏。如果你能在纽约街头上演一场边走边聊，那你就算成功了，孩子。所以当时我正在和迈克尔·道格拉斯拍这场戏，我转过身对他说：“迈克尔，这是我在纽约市的第一次边走边聊。”他转过身看着我，他瞬间秒懂了。他说：“什么？你开玩笑吧。
This is fantastic. I'm your first New York City walk and talk. Congrats. It was everything I wanted the moment to be. Well, so flash forward to I'm on The Office and they write this joke in this episode that Michael Skarn's wife is Catherine Zeta-Jones cut cut even more forward, their kids are now, I think, big fans of The Office. And she started posting about The Office. So I got up the courage to DM her on Insta. You slid into Catherine Zeta-Jones DMs.
这太棒了。我是你纽约街头第一次边走边聊的对象。恭喜啊。”这简直就是我希望那个时刻成为的所有样子。好吧，镜头快进到我参演《办公室》，他们在这集里写了一个笑话，说迈克尔·斯坎的妻子是凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯。镜头再快进，现在他们的孩子，我想，也成了《办公室》的超级粉丝。她开始在网上发帖谈论《办公室》。于是我鼓起勇气在Instagram上给她发了私信。你竟然去私信骚扰凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯。
I did. And we've had a nice little DM relationship ever since. And then I became brave enough to ask her if she would please, please record our summary. And that brings us to now. Okay, well, Catherine, I don't know you, but that was fantastic, and thank you so much. Thank you. Now, can I go into fast facts, Angela?
我真的发了。从那以后，我们有了一段非常愉快的私信交往。然后我变得足够勇敢，问她是否愿意，求求她帮我们录一段总结。这就是我们现在的由来。好吧，凯瑟琳，我不认识你，但那真的太棒了，非常感谢你。谢谢。好了，安吉拉，我可以进入快速冷知识环节了吗？
Please go into your fast facts. Fast fact number one, big news, everybody. Big news. At two minutes, 50 seconds, Mindy's hair is down. It is down. Why do you wanna fricking steal one of my big note cards? Damn it, Jenna, that my running bit about Mindy's hair
请开始你的快速冷知识吧。快速冷知识一号，重磅消息，各位。重磅消息。在两分五十秒处，敏迪（Mindy）的头发是披散着的。真的是披着的。你凭什么要抢我的一张大便签卡？可恶，珍娜，我那个关于敏迪发型的常驻烂梗
is your running bit. My running bit. It's not our running bit. It's mine. Oh, I have to admit it is kind of yours. You started it. Okay, yes. It's a half up half down. But it's very flowy. Very flowy. We are starting our transition to all down. This is half up half down because on Halloween there were these braids, but you said it didn't count because it was a costume. That's right. And I also claimed that I thought the first time we were going to see
明明是我的常驻梗。我的常驻梗。这不是我们俩的梗。是我的。哦，我得承认，这确实有点像你的梗。是你先开的头。好吧，是的。那是半扎半披的发型。但它非常飘逸。非常飘逸。我们正在开始向全披发过渡。这是半扎半披，因为在《万圣节》里有那些辫子，但你说那不算数，因为那是万圣节服装。没错。而且我也曾声称，我认为我们第一次见到
her hair down was casino night, so I stand corrected. It is two minutes, 50 seconds, the client. The client. Also in that scene, I think we're getting closer to the Kelly Kapoor we will all know and love. Oh, she was giggly. She was like, say it's not your fiance. Yes.
她披散头发会是在《赌场之夜》，所以我得收回我的话。就是两分五十秒，《客户》。《客户》。同样在那个场景中，我觉得我们越来越接近我们都熟知并喜爱的凯莉·卡普尔（Kelly Kapoor）了。哦，她当时咯咯直笑。她当时就像是在说：“快说这不是你的未婚夫。”是的。
Bright, giggly, no more morose, French twist, Kelly Kapoor. For those of you who've been listening to the podcast here, you know why this fast fact was so big for Jenna and I. Kelly's hair is almost all the way down. We've been tracking her transformation. When will she become Mindy? We're almost there. Speaking of hair, what is up with John's hair in this episode?
开朗、咯咯笑着，再也没有阴郁的法式盘头造型的凯莉·卡普尔了。对于那些一直收听这个播客的听众来说，你们懂得为什么这个快速冷知识对我和珍娜来说这么重要。凯莉的头发几乎完全披散下来了。我们一直在追踪她的蜕变过程。她什么时候才会真正变成敏迪？我们快要成功了。说到头发，乔恩（John）在这集里的发型是怎么回事？
Did you notice? Well, it's like, it kind of like is flipping out a little. No, the front, like the bangs that are usually kind of like sloppy and real cute. They're like shellacked a little bit. Well, it looks like someone just took a pair of scissors and just did a real blunt horizontal cut. Well, I have said, I feel like he has a bowl haircut for a long time. Yeah, this is the most bowl I've ever seen.
你注意到了吗？嗯，它有点像，有点往外翘。不，是前面，通常那种有点凌乱而且超级可爱的刘海。它们被弄得有点像上了发胶一样硬邦邦的。嗯，看起来就像有人拿了一把剪刀直接剪了一个非常生硬的水平发型。好吧，我一直都说，我觉得他留了个锅盖头很长一段时间了。对，这是我见过的最像锅盖头的一次。
So guys, you can check that out. Fast fact number two, Tim Meadows. Guest stars in this episode as the Lackawanna County representative Christian. I feel like we had this rule where we weren't going to do any stunt casting. And this is the first time we broke that rule. But we had to because he was so good.
所以大家，你们可以去注意一下。快速冷知识二号，蒂姆·梅多斯。作为客串演员在本集中饰演拉克万纳县（Lackawanna County）的代表克里斯蒂安（Christian）。我觉得我们曾有过一个规定，就是不搞任何噱头选角（stunt casting）。这是我们第一次打破这个规定。但我们不得不这么做，因为他太优秀了。
He's so good. And actually, Jenna and I both know Tim, and I was able to connect with him this week, and we hopped on the phone and talked about this episode, and he was so delightful. So I have some fun Tim tidbits for this episode, and I'll get to those here in a minute. Well, I didn't work the day that they shot the scenes with Tim,
他真的太棒了。事实上，我和珍娜都认识蒂姆，我本周还跟他取得了联系，我们通了电话，聊了聊这一集，他整个人真的非常讨人喜欢。所以我有一些关于蒂姆的有趣花絮要分享，我一会儿就会讲到。好吧，蒂姆拍那些戏的那天我没上班，
but I was such a big SNL fan that I went up to the set just to meet him and I had lunch with him. I was, I totally fan girled. And eventually we would end up doing the movie Walk Hard together. And so I actually got to work with him, talk about fan girl. I did a pilot with Tometo's for Fox called The Gabriels
但我太喜欢周六夜现场（SNL）了，所以我还是去了片场，只为了见他一面，还跟他一起吃了午餐。我当时真的是彻底化身小迷妹了。最终我们还一起合作了电影《永不止步：戴伊·科克斯的故事》（Walk Hard）。所以我真的有机会和他合作，说到追星，我曾和蒂姆·梅多斯一起为福克斯（Fox）拍过一部试播集，名叫《加布里埃尔一家》（The Gabriels），
and Rob Riggle was in it and we had so much fun. He is so hilarious. He's a hoot. Did I just say he's a hoot so much fun. He is so hilarious. He's a hoot. Did I just say he's a hoot? Am I a nerd? You did say he is a hoot. Why don't you give us a fast fact. Fast fact number three.
罗伯·里格尔（Rob Riggle）也在里面，我们玩得超级开心。他太搞笑了。他简直是个活宝。我刚才是不是说他是个活宝？太好玩了。他太搞笑了。他简直是个活宝。我刚才是不是说他是个活宝？我是个书呆子吗？你确实说了他是个活宝。你为什么不给我们来个快速冷知识呢。快速冷知识三号。
This episode was inspired by an idea that they had in the writer's room early on that Jim and Pam would go on a date without really being on a date. So that was the card that they put up on the wall. How can we get Jim and Pam on a date without really being on a date? But then they also wanted to do the same thing
这一集的灵感来自于编剧室很早就有的一个构想：吉姆和潘在并非真正约会的情况下进行一次约会。这就是他们贴在墙上的便签卡。我们如何能在吉姆和潘并非真正约会的情况下让他们去约会呢？但随后他们也想对迈克尔和简
with Michael and Jan. They thought it would be really fun to have both of these couples have this romantic evening. Right, sort of have a convention within the work day that they would somehow end up on a date. They also had the end of this episode written first. And then they wrote toward that ending. So that look that you see between Jim and Michael
如法炮制。他们觉得让这两对情侣都拥有这样一个浪漫的夜晚会非常有趣。对，就像是在工作日期间搞出一个“私会”，让他们阴差阳错地开始了一场约会。他们还把这一集的结局放在最开始就写好了。然后他们顺着那个结局往回写。所以你看到吉姆和迈克尔之间
at the very end of the episode where they both kind of shrug together like, ugh. The ladies. The ladies. The ladies in our lives. They knew that that would be the ending and then they tracked it back. Interesting. Because another thing that they wanted was this moment where Jim and Michael relate and bond over something.
在这一集最后那种无奈地一起耸耸肩的表情，就像在说：“唉。”女人们啊。女人们。我们生命中的女人们。他们知道那会是结局，然后他们倒推着完成了剧集。很有意思。因为他们想要的另一个瞬间，就是吉姆和迈克尔产生共鸣并因某事建立羁绊的时刻。
So that's what they decided it would be. Those are my fast facts. Okay. Can I start my note cards? I think we have to take a break. What is with you today? What is with you? What is going on? I don't know. We are taping this like two days before the Christmas holiday week. I am in check it off the list mode. It is pretty funny though because you're saying something and then I'm just looking at you and you're like,
所以这就是他们最终决定的方案。这就是我的快速冷知识。好吧。我可以开始宣读我的便签卡了吗？我想我们得休息一下了。你今天是怎么回事？你到底怎么了？这到底是怎么一回事？我不知道。我们录这期节目的时候，大概距离圣诞节假期还有两天。我已经进入“把事情勾掉打勾”的模式了。不过这其实挺搞笑的，因为你说了半天，然后我只是看着你，你就会说：
that's it, you got nothing? I know, you're just staring at me or nodding. And I'm like, it's an audio show. You have to give some audio cue that you've heard me. Are you done? Okay. All right, we're going to a break. I did it. She did nothing again.
“这就没了，你没话说了？”我知道，你只是盯着我或者点头。然后我就觉得，这是个音频节目。你总得给点音频提示，让我知道你听见我说话了吧。你说完了吗？好吧。好了，我们要进入中场休息了。我做到了。她又什么都没说。
I did it, I did it. Hey, we have a pretty special guest in this episode. We do, coming up after the break, we're gonna talk to Melora Hardin. I did it. Hey, we have a pretty special guest in this episode. We do. Coming up after the break, we're going to talk to Melora Harden. Who plays Jan. Yeah. We had to talk to her because we were not at the Chili's. No. So we had no firsthand knowledge of the Chili's, of the kissing.
我做到了，我做到了。嘿，我们在这一集里有一个非常特殊的嘉宾。没错，休息回来后，我们要和梅洛拉·哈丁聊聊。我做到了。嘿，我们在这一集里有一个非常特殊的嘉宾。没错。休息回来后，我们将与梅洛拉·哈丁交谈。饰演简的演员。对。我们必须和她聊聊，因为我们当时不在奇利斯餐厅现场。没错。所以我们对奇利斯餐厅、对那个吻都没有第一手资料。
That's smooch. We had to go straight to the source. So when we get back from the break, we're going to talk to Melora. Yay. So when we get back from the break, we're going to talk to Mellora. Yay! This episode is brought to you by Samsung Galaxy. Ever captured a great night video only for it to be ruined by that one noisy talker? With audio erase on the new Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra, you can reduce or remove unwanted
那个吻。我们只能直接去找当事人。所以等我们休息回来后，我们要和梅洛拉聊聊。耶！所以等我们休息回来后，我们要和梅洛拉聊聊。耶！本期节目由三星Galaxy赞助播出。你是否曾经拍到过精彩的夜间视频，却被某个吵闹的说话者给毁了？有了全新三星Galaxy S25 Ultra上的音频橡皮擦功能，你可以减少或移除不想要的
noise and relive your favorite moments without the distractions. And that's not all. Every week on the MOF Podcast, we share stories that are funny, strange, heartbreaking, and above all, true. I myself have been married for 56 years. Unfortunately to four different women. You can work out a whole lot of s*** in the hours of Target. Follow and listen to The Moth on the free Odyssey app or wherever you get your podcasts. All right, Angela, let's call Melora. Let's call her.
噪音，重温你最喜欢的时刻，而不会受到干扰。还不止这些。每周在莫斯播客（The Moth Podcast）上，我们都会分享一些有趣、奇怪、心碎，最重要的是真实的故事。我自己已经结婚56年了。遗憾的是对象是四个不同的女人。你可以在几小时的塔吉特（Target）逛街中解决掉一大堆破事。在免费的Audyssey应用上或在你获取播客的任何地方关注并收听The Moth。好了，安吉拉，我们给梅洛拉打电话吧。我们给她打电话。
Sam, call Melora. Hello? Melora! Hello! Hi, guys. Hi. Hi. How are you?
萨姆，给梅洛拉打电话。喂？梅洛拉！喂！嗨，各位。嗨。嗨。你好吗？
Oh, man. I'm great. Hello? Melora! Hello! Hi guys! Hi! Hi! How are you? Oh man, we're great. It's so great to hear your voice. Nice to hear yours too. It's been a long time. Melora, thank you so much for agreeing to do this.
哦，天哪。我很好。喂？梅洛拉！喂！嗨，各位！嗨！嗨！你好吗？哦，天哪，我们很好。听到你的声音真好。听到你们的声音也很好。好久不见了。梅洛拉，非常感谢你答应来做这个节目。
The fans are going to go crazy. Let's get started by asking you, how did you end up on the office? That's hilarious. Well, I got called last minute. It was sort of a last minute, like, come in and read for this. So we were like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this.
粉丝们绝对会疯狂的。让我们先问你一个问题，你是怎么加入《办公室》的？这太搞笑了。嗯，我是最后一分钟接到电话的。那有点像临时通知，比如“来为这个角色试镜吧”。所以我们当时就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。
And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I was like, oh, I'm going to read for this. And I's hilarious. Well, I got called last minute. It was sort of a last minute, like come in and read for this, which I did. And I remember that, you know, I went in and like, you know, literally looked at the sides right there before I went in because it was that last minute.
然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。然后我就觉得，哦，我要去为这个试镜。这太搞笑了。嗯，我是最后一分钟接到电话的。那有点像临时通知，比如“来为这个试镜吧”，然后我就去了。我记得，你知道的，我进去了，然后字面意思上就是在进去之前当场看了一下剧本台词，因为实在是太临时了。
Wow. You know, it was like Ken Quapus was in the room and so was Greg Daniels. And, you know, I could feel everybody was kind of excited and Allison Jones, our casting director. You know, you can always feel that as an actor, right? When it goes well and people are responding to what you're doing. Sure.
哇。你知道的，肯·克瓦皮斯（Ken Kwapis）当时在房间里，格雷格·丹尼尔斯也在。而且，你知道的，我能感觉到每个人都挺兴奋的，还有我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones）。作为演员，你总是能感觉到那种氛围，对吧？当试镜顺利进行并且大家对你的表演有积极反馈时。当然。
And then the next day I was testing for a pilot and Allison Jones was casting that as well. She came out into the hallway and I was about to go in for my test. And I was like, oh was like about really fun yesterday i really like that you know the fact that she's like yeah and i think maybe i'll get you know maybe i'll get about because that was a the character of jan at the time for the pilot with that guest star possible
然后第二天我要为一个试播集进行电视台高管试镜（test），艾莉森·琼斯也负责那个项目的选角。她走到走廊里，正当我准备进去参加试镜的时候。我就说，哦……昨天真的很开心，我真的很喜欢那个，你知道，事实上她当时就觉得“对啊，我觉得也许我会得到……也许我会得到这个角色”，因为那是试播集里简这个角色的定位，当时可能是一个客串，也可能是
recurring character but this one that i was testing for with the lead character regular in a pilot for an actor, you wanna get the pilot because when you're the regular or one of the stars of the show, because that's better money and just seems better. And she's like, well, I really want you to get that one, meaning the office.
潜在的常驻角色，但我当时正在试镜的那个项目是一个试播集里的主角、常规角色，对于演员来说，你当然更想拿下那个试播集，因为当你成为剧中的常规演员或主演之一时，那意味着更好的片酬，感觉也更好。然后她说：“嗯，我其实更希望你拿下那个角色，”指的是《办公室》。
She really wanted me to get the office. Anyway, I went in, I did the pilot test. I didn't get the pilot test, but I did get the office. Wow. Well, The Client is a very big episode for Michael and Jan. Oh yeah. It is. This is where you have your smooch in the parking lot.
她真的很希望我能拿到《办公室》的角色。总之，我进去了，我参加了那个试播集的试镜。我没拿到那个试播集的角色，但我确实拿下了《办公室》。哇。好吧，《客户》对迈克尔和简来说是非常重要的一集。哦，是的。确实如此。这就是你们在停车场接吻的那一集。
We have a fan who wrote in, his name is Ryan, and he asked, how far in advance did you know about Michael and Jan's relationship? Well, when we were filming The Pilot, I remember sitting at the tables having lunch with Greg Daniels and Steve Carell. We were all laughing at how kind of weirdly interesting Jan and Michael were together. Like we sort of, and we were like, well, yeah, that's funny. You know, if we get it, if we get it, if we get a pickup and we get an opportunity to do this more of the show than just the six that we're doing,
我们有一位粉丝写信进来，他叫瑞恩（Ryan），他问：“你们提前多久知道迈克尔和简的关系的？”嗯，当我们正在拍摄试播集时，我记得当时我们坐在桌旁和格雷格·丹尼尔斯还有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）一起吃午餐。我们都在笑着讨论简和迈克尔在一起是多么诡异地有趣。就好像我们当时觉得，我们当时说：“好吧，是的，这挺有意思的。你知道的，如果我们成功获续订，如果我们能得到续订，并且有机会在剧中更多地展现这一点，而不仅仅是我们正在拍的那六集，”
which was our first season. Then, you know, it'll be fun. We should have them hook up. Wow. Because we kind of felt like there was a little spark between them and we kind of conjured it on the pilot. Well, you guys had fantastic chemistry and I think they were all picking up on that
也就是我们的第一季。那，你知道的，这会很有趣。我们应该让他们俩勾搭上。哇。因为我们当时隐约觉得他们之间有点火花，我们在拍试播集的时候就把这种感觉给“召唤”出来了。好吧，你们俩有着不可思议的化学反应，而且我认为所有人都感受到了这一点，
and seeing the possibilities because you and Steve in scenes together were just amazing. You know what else is like everybody is so perfectly cast in this show. I mean that's one of the things I think that makes the show besides the writing which is unbelievable but also just every single person is perfectly cast. There's not one person that you look at and go, well, you know, eh. I mean, everybody's just absolutely spot on. I agree.
并且看到了其中的可能性，因为你和史蒂夫在场景中的对手戏简直太棒了。你知道吗，这剧里每个人的选角都完美得无可挑剔。我的意思是，我认为这也是让这部剧大获成功的因素之一，除了那好得令人难以置信的剧本之外，就是剧中的每一个演员都选得完美无缺。没有一个人是你看着会觉得“嗯，也就那样”的。我的意思是，每一个人都绝对精准到位。我完全同意。
I agree. Oh, jinx. Okay, well, Mallory, can we ask you a little bit about what it was like filming those scenes in that Chili's? I mean, how did you get through those scenes? I was dying laughing. Oh, it is ridiculous. I will say that the stuff that Steve and...
我完全同意。哦，心有灵犀。好吧，梅洛拉，我们可以问问你，在奇利斯餐厅拍那些戏是什么体验吗？我的意思是，你们是怎么撑过那些场景的？我当时笑得快死过去了。哦，那简直太荒谬了。我必须得说，史蒂夫和……
Tim Meadows. Tim Meadows. He's actually a friend of ours. He was so great in that. He is so fricking funny. And the stuff that they did and the improv that they did, and it just flattened me. I mean, and I swear, last night when I was watching it,
蒂姆·梅多斯。蒂姆·梅多斯。他其实是我们的朋友。他在里面的表现太棒了。他简直搞笑极了。他们当时演的内容，还有他们即兴发挥的部分，真的把我彻底击垮了。我的意思是，我发誓，昨晚当我重新看这一集的时候，
I watched it with my husband and and you know i was just like i kept going i was so hard to keep my cake i got a card so i was so amazed at how incredibly straight-faced i was because i'm telling you every time we cut i think it's a perfect fit the black
我是和我的丈夫一起看的，你知道的，当时我就觉得……我一直在想，我当时怎么能做到表情这么难以置信地严肃呢，因为我跟你讲，每次我们一喊停，我觉得这完全契合……那个黑屏，
and i had to look so irritated so you don't feel like just completely put off by all the stuff they were doing. But in reality, it was tough. So do you remember anything in particular that those guys improvised? Like was the Baby Back Ribs song, was that improvised? Yes, I think that was. That whole little section there was really, I think that really was just spur the moment the way that they
而且我当时必须表现得很生气的样子，这样你才不会觉得被他们俩搞出来的那些把戏完全恶心到。但现实中，那真的太难了。所以你还记得这几个家伙当时有什么特别的即兴发挥吗？比如那个“肋排之歌”，那是即兴发挥吗？是的，我想是的。那整小段其实真的，我觉得完全就是即兴发挥，因为他们
They kind of went back and forth. Well, I have to move us along Yes, we have another fan question that i'm actually um dying to hear because when I rewatched it I was like, oh my god, I forgot how long you and steve kissed You really smooched quite a bit David r. Carroll said, BJ Novak has been quoted as saying that the kiss between Michael and Jan was rehearsed and filmed many, many, many times. I don't remember rehearsing it.
你一言我一语地互动了起来。好吧，我得把话题推进一下。是的，我们还有另一个粉丝问题，我其实……呃……非常渴望听到答案，因为当我重看这一集时，我就想：“哦天哪，我都忘了你和史蒂夫吻了那么长时间。”你们俩真的疯狂热吻了好一会儿。大卫·R·卡罗尔（David R. Carroll）说，据引述，BJ·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）曾表示，迈克尔和简之间的吻是经过排练并拍摄了非常、非常、非常多次的。我不记得我们排练过。
I'm certain that when we rehearsed it, we certainly didn't kiss during the rehearsal. No. And actually, last night when I watched it, it I was like that was a really sweet and like kind of awkwardly just bumpy bumbly kiss that I kind of loved. I thought it was a really great first kiss for the two of them. Yeah do you remember any direction that Greg gave you during that scene? I don't remember. I really think we did it like one time or two times. I don't even know what BD is talking about. I remember it being really quick and I actually think that the take that you see on there is the first time
我敢肯定，当我们排练时，我们在排练期间绝对没有亲吻。没有。而且事实上，昨晚当我重新看的时候，我觉得那是一个非常甜蜜、有点笨拙又有点磕磕绊绊的吻，我其实挺喜欢。我觉得对于他们俩的初吻来说，这真的很棒。是的，你还记得格雷格在那个场景中给过你什么指导吗？我不记得了。我真的觉得我们大概只拍了一次或两次。我甚至不知道BJ在胡说八道些什么。我只记得当时拍得非常快，而且我实际上觉得你们在成片里看到的那个镜头就是我们第一次
we did it. So I feel like and it just has all that. It has everything it needs in it. You know it has the tension. It has the kind of like wait that's so wrong and wait a second I want more of that. kind of thing that Jan, I think, struggled with the entire relationship with Michael. So I love that. Well, that was really a spy shot. I know that Randall was crouched behind a car and he had this idea of shooting through the car window to you.
拍的那个版本。所以我觉得它包含了所有需要的东西。它具备了所有该有的元素。你知道的，它有那种紧张感。有那种“等等，这太离谱了”的感觉，还有“等一下，我还想要更多”的那种情绪，我认为简在和迈克尔的整个恋爱关系中一直在与这种纠结心理作斗争。所以我很喜欢这一点。好吧，那其实是一个偷拍镜头。我知道兰德尔（Randall）当时蹲在一辆车后面，他想出了透过车窗向你们拍摄的主意。
And I remember doing some scenes like that and they always felt so real because you couldn't feel the camera, you know, a foot away from you. You really felt like you were out in a parking lot. Exactly. You really do feel like you're in the middle of nowhere doing your own thing, having that private moment that we're all trying to strive for at all times as actors. Well, Melora, there is a scene in The Chilis I thought you did such a phenomenal job in. It's at the end of the night, and you guys, you've had a few drinks, you're over it. They're having beers and talking,
我记得我们拍过一些那样的场景，它们总是感觉那么真实，因为你根本感觉不到摄像机就在离你一英尺远的地方。你真的会觉得自己就像是在停车场里。完全没错。你真的会觉得自己身处荒郊野岭，做着自己的事情，拥有那种我们所有演员在任何时候都在极力争取的私密时刻。好吧，梅洛拉，在奇利斯餐厅里有一场戏，我觉得你演得简直太惊艳了。那是夜深人静的时候，你们俩已经喝了几杯，你已经彻底无语了。他们在喝着啤酒聊天，
and you're just sort of checked out, and then you realize that Michael is about to close the deal. You see what he's doing, and you perk up, and you look at him with this smile on your face, and that was the moment for me that I realized why she even entertained being in a relationship with Michael. She saw that side of him and was like,
而你当时已经有点魂游天外、放空自我了，接着你突然意识到迈克尔马上就要签下这笔生意了。你看出他在做什么了，然后你整个人精神一振，脸上带着微笑看着他，对我和来说，那一刻就是我意识到为什么她甚至会考虑和迈克尔谈恋爱的原因。她看到了他那一面，然后觉得……
oh my God, he's crushing it. And it totally made everything make sense for me. But you did a great job. It is a great moment. And it's, Jan really rarely smiles in the show. It is a great moment. And it's, Jan really rarely smiles in the show. Yeah. I do so much scowling and kind of, you know, a disapproving look.
And so it's really nice to see her kind of have that big full expression of, you know, kind of enjoyment of, oh my God, this whole thing that, you know, that he's been doing all night that I thought was just a bunch of BS actually was you know there was a method to his madness and I do love that and and I think that is the thing that leads to the kiss is that he feels the you know he gets to have the the moment of victory and and she has you know and she kind of is like oh there's more there's more to this guy than I thought you know he's not just this idiot that I thought he was. Yeah, yeah.
Melora, thank you so much. Yes, Melora. For taking the time to talk to us about this. Will you consider coming back for future episodes, perhaps? Oh, sure. Well, when you get to the dinner party, we'll probably. That is what I was gonna say. I mean, it is like one of the best episodes ever,
and you're so phenomenal in it. Well, you guys are sweet and what an amazing thing we've been part of together with the office and everything. It's really exciting and I love that you guys are doing this for the fans and revisiting all this. It was really fun watching the episode last night. All right, well great. We'll see you for dinner party, lady.
All right, I'll see you then. Thanks, Melora. Bye. Bye, you guys. Angela, see you for dinner party, lady. All right, I'll see you then. Thanks, Melora. Bye. Bye, you guys. Angela, I think we should get into this episode. Let's start talking about the client. Okay, can we talk about Michael and his jeans? Yes.
Oh my gosh, this cold open made me laugh so hard. I just think it's really funny that when Michael is dancing around in his jeans, there's this tiny spy shot of Angela Martin's head that's to the left of the potted plant while Michael is dancing on in his jeans. There's this tiny spy shot of Angela Martin's head that's to the left of the potted plant while Michael is dancing on the end table. And she's just looking there snarky, but I'm so short. My head barely comes over the partition.
And so there's the plant and then my head just for like a split second at 18 seconds. And then back again, when he's goofing off, I'm like judging him from the copier. So Angela Martin is just being placed in these little spaces in the background judging. Well, I remember that I had to have a big wardrobe fitting of quote unquote casual clothes
so that we could shoot these flashbacks to Casual Fridays. Oh yeah. But Angela, are you just wearing your regular gray office wear? I never participate in Casual Friday. What's interesting to me is that this cold open implies that we have Casual Fridays at the office, but so far we've never shown a Casual Friday or referenced a Casual Friday, and I believe we never do again, even though we very often have episodes set on a Friday. No, this is the one time. I said
also there's some real great Pam sass in this cold open because what do you do at the end? You just chunk his jeans under the- Chunk them? Yes, you just, you flip them over and you toss them. Have you been saying chunk your whole life? It's chuck. You chuck them.
Wait, no. Have you been saying chunk for your whole life? I think I have. I think I said you chunk it or something. Chunk it? Sam, Sam, it's a chuck, right? It's chuck. It's 100% chuck. Some people. Another Wiffle.
Oh my God. Do you chunk your Wiffle ball? I chunk it. You chunk it? Chunk it real hard at someone. Oh my God. I have to take my glasses off because I'm crying. I'm crying.
Why am I having so much? I chunk it. You don't chunk it. Oh man. Oh Lord. Yeah. Pam chucks the jeans. I'm crying, I'm laughing so hard. I chunk it. You don't chunk it. Oh, man.
Oh, Lord. Yeah, Pam chucks the jeans into the trash. Well, there is some Pam sass there. There is. Also, how long in my life have I been saying things wrong? And now I'm just learning about it all on the podcast. I don't know. Oh, God.
Okay. Well, that is life intimidating art right there. Okay, so after the scene with the jeans, the show opens with Michael and Jan having a meeting. They're talking about how they're hoping to secure a very big account, Lackawanna County, the whole county. They will buy their paper from Dunder Mifflin. This is when Michael tells Jan he has changed the meeting from the Radisson, which he describes as too snooty, to Chili's, which he says is the new golf course where business happens.
Yes, I have that on a card. I thought it was so funny, the Radisson. Too snooty. Too snooty. Too snooty. Too stuffy. I have two note cards from this scene that I have to bring up. Oh, well then go.
I mean, at a minute 16 seconds. you guys, Jan has hot pink nail polish. She does? Yes. I think Angela Martin is probably judging her. I mean, you know, she judges her, but hot pink nail polish in the workplace, I'm just saying. And then a minute 31 seconds, Jim has a talking head and he says that if we get this big Lackawanna account, we might not have to downsize. But didn't we just downsize in the Halloween episode?
Well we let go of one person but I think the bigger deal is that they're saying an entire branch might have to close. Ah. So it's either us or Stanford. Got it. It's gonna have to close completely. Okay. So this would save us. I got it. This moves us into the scene in the kitchen where everyone is telling their worst first date stories. Oscar tells a story about how he went on a date and he found out the woman had background checked him.
The woman. Yeah. Yes. I have this on a note card. I'm like, Oscar is telling this like kind of horrible date scenario where he went on a date with a woman. So did the writers not know that they were going to make Oscar gay yet? Or is Oscar kind of covering in front of his coworkers? Well, that backstory of being on a date with someone who'd done a background check on you, that was based on a real story of Paul Lieberstein's dating
life. What? Yeah. He said he went on to date the woman for a while, but that on their first date, she revealed that she had done a real deep dive on him to make sure that he was on the up and up. I have a fan question. Both Sarah Clark and Kem asked, who came up with Pam's worst first date story? Well, Pam's story of being left at a hockey game was not based on anyone's real story,
but the writers went around the room and they just pitched worst first date stories. Where is the worst place that you could leave a date? That was their assignment one afternoon. That's a little insight into the writer's room, what it's like. They sit in there on a bunch of couches and they eat snacks. They eat a lot of snacks up there. They really do.
Cause we would go steal their snacks. We would steal their snacks, but they also do sit at a table with computers as well. Well, they do, but sometimes when they pitch these ideas, it's really fun to go in there because they'll say, okay, what is the worst place to leave a date? And then they just go around there and you just shout it out. It's like so fun in a writer's room because I feel like when
they do that kind of stuff, it's almost like playing a game of Pictionary or something in your living room. So they said that they had a lot of alternates, but this was their favorite. They liked the idea. I wish we could know what their alternates were. I know. This is the one that ended up in the script, but I think it's perfect. First of all, that he took her to a minor league hockey game on their first date. Second, that he brought his brother. And then third, that they left her there. Yeah. And then that it was Roy. Yeah. It totally supports the backstory you made up that he bought C-do's with the money
you were gonna plan your wedding with. Yeah, with his brother. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I loved it. I thought it was perfect. At three minutes, 35 seconds, in the background there is a male cart, like a rolly male cart.
Oh yeah, it's there a lot. No one ever pushes it. No one ever delivers from it. No, sometimes we've had people push that cart, I think. I feel like Oscar has done something with that cart. Really? I don't know, guys. We don't have a designated mail person though
that like comes around with their mail. We don't have a mail room. We don't. I feel like Pam handles all the mail. Well, then she just pushes the cart to the back of the room. Well, I never pushed the cart, but maybe anyone out there comment to us, let us know. Yeah, who pushes the cart to the back of the room. Well, I never pushed the cart, but maybe anyone out there comment us, let us know.
Yeah, who pushes the cart? At three minutes 54 seconds, you can see three photos on my desk. Yes, look, I have one of them. Oh, Jennet, there's a photo of your sister and her husband taped to your desk. Yes, that's right. And my sister's husband's name is Dwight.
Isn't that crazy? Now, the writers didn't know that. That was just all like by chance. Yes. Here's a little bit of interesting trivia. My father's name is Jim. My brother-in-law's name is Dwight. And my niece's name is Cece.
Well, and they named the character after Cece. Yes. The other two were already happening. Yeah. But that one was all you. My niece Cece was Yes. The other two were already happening. Yeah. But that one was all you. My niece Cece was born about a week before we filmed the episode where Pam and Jim have their baby.
And I asked if we could name their baby Cece after my niece. I think that's so cute. All right, ladies, should we take a break? I think we should. I see you've pared down your note cards here. I'm paring down my note cards. I've collected myself. I'm no longer laughing at you
when you just simply look at me. Thank you. I'm thankful for admitting that all I'm doing is looking at you. I know, but the expression was really funny. Now you just did it again. You just implied that there's some way I'm looking at you. This is your thing.
I'm gonna take a sneaky photo of your face. Don't you dare. Lady, you do. I have to do the impression. Ready? This is my impression. I'm gonna take a sneaky photo of your face. Don't you dare. Lady, you do. I have to do the impression. Ready? This is my impression. You be me. Look down at your note, whatever you're doing.
Okay. Ready? And those are my fast facts. Nothing? You have nothing? Angela, this is a podcast. You're supposed to talk. That's my impression. But did you see my face?
Barely. Those are my fast facts. And those are my fast facts. Your turn. Okay, we are back. Michael and Jan are getting ready to leave to go to Chili's for their big meeting. And did you notice in the parking lot, Michael says Chili's is just a couple blocks away. They should just drive together.
However, the closest Chili's is actually about 30 minutes away in Wilkes-Barre at the Wyoming Valley Mall. Somebody did a little bit of a deep dive. I remember this. I remember when we were shooting it that we discovered that there isn't really a Chilies in Scranton. You have to go outside to get there. And it wasn't a big deal when we did the Dundeeies, but here Michael does say it's only a couple blocks away, but it's not.
And then he goes on to say, you don't know Scranton at all. Which is like, well, maybe, maybe you don't know it. What was it like for all the people in Scranton to see this episode and be like, wait, what? Where's the chilies? Well, they probably had the same moment when they saw a palm tree or two every once in a while.
They'd be like, wait, what's a palm tree doing in there? I also want to say, I looked it up, there still isn't a Chili's and Scranton Chili's. Missed opportunity here. You guys want to go ahead and put a Chili's and Scranton already? Chili's, maybe you should call us because Jenna has some business plan for you. We will cut the ribbon. Oh, we would cut the ribbon. We'll cut the ribbon.
I've never done that. That'd be fun. I know. I've always wanted to do that where you hold the giant scissors. We would cut the ribbon. I've never done that. That'd be fun. I know. I've always wanted to do that where you hold the giant scissors. Don't chunk them though. I won't chunk them Angela.
I will not chunk them at anyone. So they walk inside the Chili's to one of my all time favorite scenes. Yes. I bet it's this. I'm holding up my note card. It is. Is it, is Gould dead?
No Gould. When she says no Gould, Steve's face as Michael, when he whips around and goes, no Gould. You see everything in him go electric. Yes. Is Gould dead? Do you want to talk about it? Are you okay? We're in a meeting, Michael. Michael, we're in a meeting. And then he has to give that look to camera. Yeah. Oh my God. It's so good. Oh man, Steve is so good in that scene.
Oh, we have the same thing written down now. What? I just peeked at your note card, the waitress Megan. You hold your paper up so I can't see it, but my note cards are right here in front of you. That's your business. Five minutes, 47 seconds. Megan, may we have an awesome blossom, please?
I think this is a great detail. Now, I don't know if this was in the script. I don't know if Steve improvised that, but I love that Michael remembers the waitress by name. I absolutely believe that the character of Michael would remember every waiter or waitress by name. I think that Michael- Every flight attendant. Yes, I was gonna say, I think Michael knows the name
of every person he has to interact with. Yes. And it's his pleasure to get to know their name. And I love that he knows the waitress's Megan. It is a great, great detail. Six minutes, 19 seconds, Michael calls Pam on the phone back at the office to get him to read her a bunch of jokes from these joke books in his office. I got a lot of questions about this, people wanting to know the punchline for that joke about the lighthouse that Pam starts and Michael's like, no, no, no, no, no, no. No, no, no, not that one. There is no punchline to the joke.
It was not in the book. Those jokes, quote unquote, were scripted and they just wrote the beginning of the jokes. Oh, I love it. There were no endings. I bet the writers had a lot of fun with that. Just writing the first line of a joke that they know they don't have to worry about the payoff, that would have been fun. Well, and I had the challenge of having to memorize the line, but look like I was reading
from the book that I was not reading from. Oh yeah, that's tricky. It was a little tricky. After this, Pam finds threat level midnight, the script that Michael has written where he is an action star, Michael Scarn, and at seven minutes, 18 seconds, Jim finds drawings of the Threat Level Midnight poster within the script. And we had a fan question from Becca Ramirez. She asked, who made the drawings in the script of Threat Level Midnight?
Do you know? I don't, great question. Greg Daniels. Did he really? He made the drawings himself. Oh my gosh, I could see him sort of sitting on the side, quickly drawing them. So he sketched them out and then he gave them to,
I guess it would be Phil Shea. Yeah. And Phil hired an artist, but this was the example. And then he gave them to, I guess it would be Phil Shea. And Phil hired an artist, but this was the example. Like Greg kind of sketched it out to say, here's my idea of what the poster, this is what the drawing should look like. And Greg said the artist came back and the drawings were so good that he thought,
he thought maybe his kind of crappier drawing was more realistic. More realistic, yeah, that Michael would do that. Yeah, so he kept his own drawing in. I think it's just perfect. Okay, well, two things. Number one, here's the actual joke that Michael tells. At the Chili's.
At the Chili's, here's the actual joke. Well, I'm an astronaut, so I drive a Saturn. Second guy says, I'm a pimp, so I drive a cheap escort. Third guy says, I got you both beat. I'm a proctologist, so I drive a brown probe. Yeah. And that's the line that like makes Christian, the client, just roll over laughing. How about it's seven minutes, 36 seconds.
They're all eating this awesome blossom with no drinks, not even waters. Megan, where's their waters? Megan? I mean, those are kind of salty. You need your water. You do. Oh, I have a fan question. Okay.
So a lot of people asked if this was the same Chili's where we shot Dundee's. Yes. All right, I did some research. So we got a lot of conflicting information on this one when I went to research it. First of all, the internet says it was not the same Chili's, yet they have no citation for why.
Their information. That's right. So I asked Phil Shea, he said he thought it was the same one, but he said it was close to our set. But the original Dundee's one was not close to our set. Then I asked Greg, he said he couldn't remember, but he knows it was an empty black Angus. So, I don't know.
So I actually asked him this as well. I said, Tim, can you tell me a little bit about where you filmed? Because we're trying to figure out if it was where we filmed the Dundee's. And he said, well, I can tell you this. It was like this really gross out of business restaurant in a kind of sketchy area. So maybe it was the same. That makes me think it was the same. And he said, it was gross because no one had been in that building in so long.
There were like little nooks and crannies of it that were kind of dusty and karate. As I was watching it, I couldn't tell. If it was different, they did an excellent job of making it look like it was the same place. Yeah, I couldn't tell either, but Tim's description of it kind of brought me back. Eight minutes, 34 seconds, Michael's tie with the little mouth on it that he uses to eat the awesome blossom. That was scripted that he would do that.
And the wardrobe designer actually had to make that tie. That is a custom-made tie. She made seven different mouth options that she showed to Greg, and he had to pick the mouth that would go on the tie. Oh my gosh. This is when when I'm like our jobs are crazy. That is a crazy thing. Hey how was your day? Well I had to make ties with mouths on them like a bunch of different mouths. I made I made seven different mouths and then my boss picked one. Okay can we get to one of my favorite scenes which is nine minutes seven seconds the baby back ribs. Yes.
All right, I was so excited to talk to Tim about this. Now, a lot of you guys wrote in and said, was that improvised, was it scripted? And here's what Tim said. Tim said the beginning of that song, when Michael starts off singing, was in the script, and in the script that he was supposed to join in at the end.
Okay. Baby back ribs, right? Yeah. At the end. And he Baby back ribs, right? Yeah. At the end. And he said when they started filming it, Steve started to sing and it just kind of wasn't working when Tim joined in. So Tim started doing the other part, just kind of improvised that, I want my baby back, baby back, baby back.
Yeah. And then it was like lightning bolt. Off to the races. We've got it. And he said one of his favorite moments, it's in the bloopers and I went and watched it, is he goes to do his, I want my baby back back. And Steve just improvises, no, you come in later. And he's like, oh yeah, right.
Like, and it's so funny. It's a great little moment in the bloopers. I watched those deleted scenes as well. So good. So good. And Melora is right, Melora could not hold it together. I mean, can you blame her? No.
They were so funny. And they really wanted to hold that three shot. They really wanted her to be the anchor of the scene so they couldn't carve it up. They couldn't have all these singles or anything. So anytime she laughed. They had to start again. They did. You can also tell that those guys are having so much fun singing together.
They're having start again. They did. You can also tell that those guys are having so much fun singing together. They're having a blast. The week after this scene, Steve was going to shoot to host Saturday Night Live. When I was there that day, I remember Tim giving him some little- Yeah, all the insider info on what it would be like. Well, I actually said to Tim, I was like, Tim, you and Steve had such great chemistry. How long have you known each other? And he said, we've actually known each other a really, really long time.
So they met a long, long time ago before any of them were famous. When they were really young, they were all at Second City in Chicago. And they also did Improv Olympic. And then Tim was cast on SNL with Nancy Carell and Dave Keckner. Oh my gosh.
Right? But he said, honestly, he said when they became really, really tight and got to know each other is the summer when he had off from Saturday Night Live, all of those guys went and did a second city tour in DC. And they were there for the summer. And he said, that was so much fun. He said they would do their show. And then after the show,
they would all stay and do an improv set. And he said it's some of the best improv he's ever been a part of. Could you imagine if you could go back in time and buy a ticket to that show? I would have loved it. There are people who got to see that. Yeah, and Tim said, I was like, who was in the cast?
And he said it was Steve and Nancy, John Glaser, Adam McK said, I was like, who was in the cast? And he said it was Steve and Nancy, John Glaser, Adam McKay, Teresa Mulligan, who I know, who is hilarious. And they just had the best time. Well, some of the most fun we ever had, Angela, off camera on our show was when we would get to hang out with the cast of Saturday Night Live. Because remember, they're an NBC show, we're an NBC show. So we would often have to do press with them. We would go to New York, they would fly the cast of The Office to New York, and we would spend an entire day doing press conferences.
And then in the evenings, they would throw a little party for all of the actors on the NBC shows. And it would be the cast of The Office and the cast of Saturday Night Live, and we would just crack up. Crack up. And have dance parties. Those are some of my most fun memories.
And I even remember being there and pinching myself and thinking, remember this, remember all of this. Yes, I remember. One of the things I remember is that you and I going to watch Saturday Night Live and we got there and we were sort of hanging out with everyone, you know, before they're kind of getting ready. So we just said hi quickly. We went to our seats and then afterwards we went back in their dressing rooms and hung out like another half hour. Then we went to this like after party
that they have after every one, every taping. That was really cool. But then Chris Parnell was like, guys, do you want to go to the after party really cool. But then Chris Parnell was like, "'Guys, do you wanna go to the after party?' The after after party. And I was like, wait, isn't this the after party? And he goes, no, no, no, the after after party. And then we went to the after after party and it was like in this bar, Jenna,
that looked like a forest. It had all these trees. Yeah, I remember. And you and I, like, I think I just had on like a denim dress I got at the Gap. Like, and like everyone was dressed so cool looking. And I turned to you and I, like, I think I just had on like a denim dress I got at the Gap. And like everyone was dressed so cool looking. And I turned to you and I was like, it is three in the morning. Oh, I think the sun was coming up when we finally called it a night.
I remember going up to Chris Parnell and being like, so I think we're done. He's like, all right, guys, take, they were still there. Crazy. We left and they were still there. Those are some of my favorite memories. And I'm so glad we did that stuff, because we are kind of the people who don't normally stay out late. No, we don't.
But we went for it. And I was there were two casts that we hung out with a ton in our heyday of The Office, I would say. And one of those was SNL and the other was Mad Men. Yes. Mad Men, that show was coming up at the same time I would say. And one of those was SNL, and the other was Mad Men. Yes. Mad Men, that show was coming up at the same time that we were. And I would hang out with the cast of Mad Men a lot. Also, same thing, we would have to go to these press junkets.
And the stars of all the shows would be in their various conference rooms speaking to the press. But then they'd have some, like, big buffet lunch for all of us. And I would chit chat with all the mad men people. The other cast that I ended up talking to quite a bit who I really thought were fantastic was Community. Oh yes, that's right.
Everyone on that and that show was just so cool and fun and I loved getting, when we got partnered with them, you know, to do press. Well bringing us back to the episode, you know that scene where they're eating the ribs? Yeah. Okay. I found out a really interesting little tidbit. I listened to the DVD commentary. That's actually Paul and Greg making the slurping sounds. Oh no. They recorded slurping sounds in the editing room to lay on top of that scene to just make it even grosser for Melora's reaction. That is so funny. That is so funny and just makes me like love our show because I felt like we were just like this little engine
that could, this little team of like, we need two people to make slurping sounds. Oh, that happened all the time. All the time. You have some more stuff about Tim though. What do you want to say? Well, I just asked him, you know, if he had heard of The Office
and how he came to get the job. And he said that he was a humongous fan of the BBC version. And he said that when he got the call about the show, that it was not a hit, right? It was kind of early on. It was still sort of, sort of like, what is the show about? And like he said in like inner comedy circles, people were like, the show's really funny.
So he knew it was funny, but it was like, the world didn't really know about this show yet. And he was kind of busy and he was like, I don't know guys, I don't know that I can do it. And so he initially said no. Oh, he turned it down? Yes, and then they called back and Tim said his theatrical manager's assistant was like,
Tim, this show is so hilarious. And he was like, all right, all right, all right, I'll do it. I'll do it. And he said he's so glad he did. Of course he had the best time with Steve. Thanks, Tim. So now Angela, I think we should go back into the office and talk a little bit about threat level midnight.
Oh, yes. Everyone in the office goes into the conference room, they divide up the parts and they start reading threat level midnight. I think this is a great example of what a table read is like. This is what we would do every week on the office. Tuesdays or Wednesdays at lunch, we would all go into this conference room. They would hand out the next week's script, and we would read it out loud. Yeah, and usually the director was the narrator. They would read all the stage direction. And on Threat Level Midnight, Jim is the narrator when you guys all read it, and he casts Oscar as Goldenface. But when Threat Level Midnight is actually made, Jim is Goldenface.
Yes. Yes, that's right. It's a little catch there. One of my favorite things in this is dwegged. The fact that Michael's bumbling assistant clearly used to be named Dwight. So that talking head that Pam gives where she explains the typo and all of that, the first time we shot this episode, that explanation did not exist. And so that was a reshoot. I actually like that talking head because it helped it make sense for me because Samuel L. Chang was actually dwecked.
That's right. Well, here's the cast that we see in Threat Level Midnight at the table read. Now there's, it's more fleshed out and things have changed once it's an actual movie and we see that in season seven. Phyllis is Catherine Zeta-Jones, Dwight is Michael Scarn, Oscar is Goldenface,
Ryan is Samuel L. Chang. And that's the only people that are cast in what we see. Everyone else is sort of sitting around, but those are the ones that are called out. Well, I had a big fan question here. A lot of people asked if Threat Level Midnight was a fully written script. It was written, they did write quite a bit
瑞安是塞缪尔·L·张。我们看到的演员里就只有他们俩。其他人都在周围坐着，但只有他们俩被点名了。好吧，我这里有个粉丝的很多问题。很多人问《威胁级：午夜》是不是一个写完整的剧本。它是写了，他们确实写了不少
so that we would have something to work with, but as you see in the show, it's an unfinished script, so it was not a fully written script. They also wanted to know if we read from the script or if it was improvised. I was going to say that I thought we read from the script, but I found an interview with Brian Baumgartner where he said, we improvised it, and BJ backed that up, that we were sitting around for about five to ten minutes and we were just throwing out anything at all, which seems almost impossible to me, but there's two people in the cast who say that's how it was. I remember it differently.
这样我们才有点东西可凭，但正如你在剧里看到的，它是个未完成的剧本，所以它并不是一个写完整的剧本。他们还想知道我们是照着剧本念的还是即兴发挥的。我本来想说我觉得我们是照着剧本念的，但我找到了布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳的一个采访，他说，我们是即兴发挥的，BJ也证实了这一点，说我们坐了大约五到十分钟，然后就随口瞎编了一通，这在我看来几乎是不可能的，但剧组有两个人说当时就是这样的。我的记忆跟他们不太一样。
Even Phyllis, when she said, I have two things to say. First thing is I love you. No, no, no. So I should say some of it was scripted, but we did also improvise some. Okay. So it was both. And that happened a lot when we were shooting. They would leave the cameras rolling and then we would throw stuff out there. And some of the improvisations stayed in. I love that. But you could definitely tell the beginning of the scene was scripted. Yes. Getting you into it. Yes, that's true. Back at Chili's, guys, let's have a little bit of an adult beverage timecode count. Oh, dear. So at 7 minutes 59 seconds, Jan orders a vodka tonic. We never see this vodka tonic.
就连菲莉丝也是，当她说，我有两件事要说。第一件事是我爱你。不，不，不。所以我得说，有些部分是按剧本演的，但我们确实也即兴发挥了一些。好吧。所以两者皆有。我们在拍的时候经常这样。他们会让摄像机一直开着，然后我们就在现场自由发挥。有些即兴发挥的内容保留了下来。我太喜欢了。但你绝对能看出场景的开头是按剧本来的。是的。把你带入情境。是的，没错。回到奇利餐厅，伙计们，让我们来盘点一下成人饮料的时间轴。哦，天哪。所以在7分59秒时，简点了一杯伏黛 tonic（伏特加汤力水）。我们从来没看到这杯伏特加汤力水。
Oh, that's right. Yeah. At 8 minutes, 35 seconds, they all have margaritas. So is Jan on her second drink? At 13 minutes, 44 seconds, Michael and Christian are having beers. Jan looks like she's having a water with lime. I can't tell. It's in a tall glass. Maybe that's finally her vodka tonic. I don't know.
哦，对哦。是的。在8分35秒时，他们都喝了玛格丽塔酒。所以简是在喝第二杯吗？在13分44秒时，迈克尔和克里斯蒂安在喝啤酒。简看起来像是在喝加青柠的水。我看不出来。它装在一个高脚杯里。也许那终于成了她的伏特加汤力水。我不知道。
That's our adult beverage count for those of you who love the background stuff like me. Angela, I'm ready to take us on a date. To the roof. To the roof. Pam and Jim's roof date. I have so many questions. I have so many technical questions. Okay. And then I have some just, you know, fan of the office questions. What do you want to know? How did you get up on that roof? Okay. So the ladder that you see in the episode really leads up to the roof. You really climb that little fire escape looking ladder?
这就是我们为那些和我一样喜欢背景细节的人准备的成人饮料盘点。安吉拉，我准备好带你约会了。去屋顶。去屋顶。帕姆和吉姆的屋顶约会。我有好多问题。我有好多技术层面的问题。好吧。然后我还有一些，你知道的，办公室粉丝的问题。你想知道什么？你们是怎么上去那个屋顶的？好吧。所以剧集里看到的那个梯子确实通往屋顶。你们真的爬了那个看起来像消防通道的小梯子吗？
John and I did not. That is how the crew got up there. John and I, for I guess safety reasons and insurance reasons, we got into a harness and then they lifted us up to the roof. Like in a forklift kind of thing? Yeah, in some sort of weird platformy forklift, which seemed scarier and more dangerous than if I'd just been allowed to use the ladder. And we shot on the actual roof of Dunder Mifflin, of the Dunder Mifflin building. I would rather climb the ladder. Same, I asked to climb the ladder, but we went up and down on the platform forklift.
我和约翰没有。那是工作人员上去的方式。我和约翰，我猜出于安全和保险原因，我们系上了安全带，然后他们把我们吊到了屋顶上。就像叉车那种东西吗？对，在某种奇怪的平台式叉车上，这看起来比允许我自己爬梯子还要吓人和危险。而且我们是在邓德米夫林实际的屋顶上拍的，在邓德米夫林大楼上。我宁愿爬梯子。一样，我要求爬梯子，但我们是坐着平台叉车上上下下的。
Okay. I have a fan question about the roof. Okay. James K asked, was it cold on the roof? It looked cold. It wasn't. It wasn't? Angela, shooting the scene is one of my fondest memories
好吧。我有一个关于屋顶的粉丝问题。好吧。詹姆斯·K问，屋顶上冷吗？看起来很冷。并不冷。不冷吗？安吉拉，拍这场戏是我最美好的回忆之一
of all time from the show. Because the only people on the roof were me, John, Greg Daniels, Paul Lieberstein, our first AD, and our camera operator and DP, Randall Einhorn. It was warm. It was a warm summer evening. But like a beautiful summer night. Warm breeze.
这是我从这部剧开播以来所有记忆中最深刻的一个。因为屋顶上只有我、约翰、格雷格·丹尼尔斯、保罗·利伯斯坦、我们的第一副导演，还有我们的摄影师兼DP兰德尔·艾因霍恩。天气很暖和。那是一个温暖的夏日傍晚。就像一个美好的夏夜。温暖的微风。
It was, I can't explain it, but this little group of us up on the roof, it hit me while I was up there. I'm on a TV show. I'm living my dream. This is amazing. Right. I'm sure it felt really magical. Just like a magical moment. Completely magical. We had really gelled as a group at this point. You know, we were really
那是，我无法解释，但我们这小群人在屋顶上，我在上面的时候突然意识到。我在拍电视剧。我在实现我的梦想。这太棒了。对。我敢sure那种感觉真的很神奇。就像一个神奇的时刻。完全神奇。此时此刻，我们作为一个团队已经真正融为一体了。你知道，我们真的
in it all together. We all loved the show so much. We loved being at work so much. It was just really, really special. And the grilled cheese sandwiches tasted so good. It was great. I have another fan question. Donna asked, was anyone hurt by the fireworks? That looked kind of dangerous. So I saw Brian Baumgartner recently and I asked him about the fireworks.
完全投入其中。我们都太喜欢这部剧了。我们太喜欢上班了。那段经历真的、真的很特别。而且烤奶酪三明治太好吃了。太棒了。我还有另一个粉丝问题。唐娜问，有人被烟花弄伤吗？那看起来有点危险。所以我最近见到了布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳，我向他问了关于烟花的事。
He said, Jenna, it was insane. There was no stunt coordinator for these fireworks. He said, because they had to get the shot of us from so far away, they really left the two of them out in the middle of this parking lot field alone. Which looked very dry. Yeah. Well, you know, fireworks are illegal in LA. They my gosh. They had a hard time even getting fireworks for this scene. So we were breaking the law? I'm not sure. I know BJ said once in an article that there was a rule about how big the fireworks could be. They weren't allowed to shoot anything up in the air because LA is very dry.
他说，珍娜，那太疯狂了。这些烟花没有特技指导。他说，因为他们必须从很远的地方拍我们，所以他们真的把他们俩孤零零地留在这个停车场空地的正中间。看起来非常干燥。是的。嗯，你知道的，在洛杉矶放烟花是违法的。天哪。他们甚至很难为这场戏弄到烟花。所以我们是在违法？我不确定。我记得BJ在某篇文章里说过，关于烟花的大小有一个规定。他们不被允许往空中发射任何东西，因为洛杉矶非常干燥。
That's right. I think I do know that. So you can do the thing that's on the ground, but that's it. Yes. So there were like the sparkler thing on the ground. Yes. And Brian said that they couldn't hear anything. They could barely hear action or cut. They just were out there playing in these fireworks.
没错。我想我确实知道这一点。所以你可以玩那种在地上的东西，但仅此而已。是的。所以就像地上那种仙女棒一样的东西。是的。而且布赖恩说他们什么也听不见。他们几乎听不到“开始”或“咔”。他们只是在这些烟花中玩耍。
But at a certain point, he heard someone shout, hop over them, kick them. Like stuff like that. It was probably Greg screaming. But Brian said they were just, it felt very real. And I think that was part of it about what made that night so magical was that it was really like we were watching those guys goof around with fireworks. Because they were. Because you were. Yes. Yes.
但在某个时刻，他听到有人喊，跳过去，踢它们。诸如此类的话。那可能时格雷格在大喊。但布赖恩说他们只是，感觉非常真实。我想这也是当晚之所以如此神奇的一部分原因，因为那真的就像我们在看那几个家伙和烟花胡闹。因为他们确实在胡闹。因为你们确实在。是的。是的。
And after this, when we come down from the roof, Jim and Pam, they leave the office and they're listening on the headphones. Oh, at 14 minutes, 34 seconds, I have a notecard that says, old tech alert. What? Because it's an iPod. Yes. It's an iPod and you guys have like the little headphones where you each take a little ear. It's so cute.
在这之后，当我们从屋顶下来时，吉姆和帕姆，他们离开办公室，戴着耳机在听音乐。哦，在14分34秒时，我有一张便签写着，老旧科技警报。什么？因为是个iPod。是的。是个iPod，你们戴着那种小耳机，每个人分一只耳塞。太可爱了。
Well, Matt Hurt asked, what if anything were you and John listening to when you shot the swing dancing scene? Okay, that's one of my questions too, Matt. So what was it? Okay, the song you hear in the episode is a song called Sing by Travis. But John and I were actually listening to an Interpol song. Which song? I don't remember.
嗯，马特·赫特问，你和约翰在拍摇摆舞那场戏时到底在听什么（如果有的话）？好吧，这也是我的问题之一，马特。所以到底是什么？好吧，你在剧集里听到的那首歌是特拉维斯乐队的《Sing》。但我和约翰实际上在听一首国际乐队（Interpol）的歌。哪首歌？我不记得了。
But you know it was Interpol. Yes. I remember that. And I think, I think that was John's actual iPod and that he suggested that song, that we listened to the song. Aww, Jam fans are going to love that. Yeah, and that was also lovely. Same warm summer evening.
但你知道那是国际乐队（Interpol）。对。我记得。而且我想，我觉得那是约翰自己的iPod，而且是他建议听那首歌，我们听了那首歌。天哪，Jam（吉姆和帕姆）粉丝会爱死这个的。是的，那也很美好。同样的温暖夏日傍晚。
It was awesome. So we talked to Melora a little bit about the next scene, which is Michael and Jan in the parking lot. That's at 15 minutes, 21 seconds. It is the big smooch. Yes, the big smooch. Yes, the big smooch. All right, so I feel like there's just this brilliant moment and I don't know if it was written
太棒了。所以我们和梅洛拉聊了聊下一场戏，也就是迈克尔和简在停车场。那是15分21秒。那是激情热吻。是的，激情热吻。是的，激情热吻。好吧，所以我觉得这里有一个非常精彩的瞬间，我不知道这到底是写好的
or if Steve improvised this, that just shows how over the moon giddy Michael is that him and Jan just kissed and that she said, let's get out of here. He's so giddy and I wrote down the scene because I thought it was so adorable. It's at 15 minutes 21 seconds. Jan says Jan is sort of like all of a sudden camera aware, right? Yeah. She says she's looking for the camera. Is this getting caught on tape? She doesn't find
还是史蒂夫即兴发挥的，它恰恰表现出迈克尔有多么欣喜若狂，因为他和简刚刚接吻了，而且简说，我们离开这儿吧。他太兴奋了，我把这一幕记了下来，因为我觉得太可爱了。是在15分21秒。简说简突然之间有了镜头意识，对吧？是的。她说她在找摄像机。这被拍进录像带了吗？她没有找到
the camera, but she wonders. Right. And so she says, let's go. And Michael goes, what? And she goes, let's go. And he says, where are we going? Oh, okay, doesn't matter, going to the go-go. Going to the go-go. Going to the go-go, I thought that was so cute. He's just so excited. I thought it was adorable. All right, so it's the next morning now. The Dunder Mifflin film crew enters the office.
摄像机，但她在纳闷。对。于是她说，我们走吧。迈克尔说，什么？她说，我们走吧。他说，我们要去哪儿？哦，好吧，没关系，去蹦迪吧。去蹦迪。去蹦迪，我觉得这太可爱了。他就是太兴奋了。我觉得太可爱了。好吧，现在是第二天早上了。邓德米夫林摄制组进入办公室。
Do they have a key? Do you notice that? Dwight is sleeping on the couch. Maybe it's not even locked. I know, maybe he never locked the door that night. Why is Dwight in sleeping on the couch. Maybe it's not even locked. I know. Maybe he never locked the door that night. Why is Dwight in blue underwear and his tank top under like a foil, like a FEMA foil blanket?
他们有钥匙吗？你注意到了吗？德怀特正睡在沙发上。也许门甚至根本没锁。我知道，也许他那天晚上根本没锁门。为什么德怀特穿着蓝色内裤和背心躺在类似应急铝箔毯的毯子下面？
Well, I'll tell you, there was a very big meeting about what underwear he would wear. Of course there was. Yes. Would it be boxers? Would it be briefs? What color? This is what they decided.
好吧，我来告诉你，关于他该穿什么内裤，开过一次非常大的会。当然开过。是的。是平角裤吗？还是三角裤？什么颜色？他们最后是这么决定的。
Of course there's a huge meeting about Dwight's underwear. Of course. Yeah, I know. And they decided on those blue, kind of like tighty-whities. Yeah, they're, I guess, very slouchy. Very baggy. Oh, you know, Ray loved that. He loved every second. What about the scene where he runs to the window? Angela sees Jan.
当然关于德怀特的内裤开过一个巨大的会。当然。对，我懂。他们决定穿那种蓝色的、有点像紧身三角裤的内裤。对，我猜它们非常松垮。非常肥大。哦，你知道的，雷伊很喜欢这个。他喜欢每一个瞬间。他跑向窗户的那场戏呢？安吉拉看到了简。
That's right. So obviously the camera crew busts Jan, right? She's so busted. But there are two Dunder Mifflin employees who also now know. Angela, who's arrived early in the parking lot and Dwight, who's peeping down from the window. And Jan sees Dwight.
没错。所以很明显摄像组抓包了简，对吧？她被抓了个正着。但现在还有两个邓德米夫林员工也知道了。安吉拉，她一早就到了停车场，还有德怀特，他在窗户往下偷看。而简看到了德怀特。
I'm assuming she sees Angela as she drives by, but I love that Dwight and Angela- Oh, I think she totally clocks you. Oh yeah, I do too. But I love that Dwight and Angela, who go on to have their secret relationship, totally bust Jan. I love that it's Angela in the parking lot
我猜她开车经过时也看到了安吉拉，但我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉——哦，我觉得她绝对注意到你了。哦，对，我也觉得。但我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉，他们后来发展出了秘密恋情，彻底抓包了简。我喜欢在停车场的是安吉拉
because I feel like the very last person who you wanna see during your walk of shame is Angela. Exactly. All right. So Michael arrives into the office with his delicious secret. He's so giddy. I felt like Melora described that so well, how sweet and innocent and happy he is that he- Oh, he's so excited. that he. He's so excited.
因为我觉得在你遭遇社死时，最不想见到的人就是安吉拉。没错了。好吧。所以迈克尔带着他美味的秘密来到办公室。他太兴奋了。我觉得梅洛拉把那种感觉描述得太好了，他是多么的甜美、天真和快乐——哦，他太兴奋了。他——他太兴奋了。
So good. He's so, and he really, he really is like, I'm not going to talk about it, right? No, I'm not going to speak about it. He's like, gentlemen, don't kiss and tell and neither do I. Ha ha ha. You know, and then the next thing we know, he's like, we'll have to disclose, we'll have to write a letter. Yeah.
太棒了。他太，而且他真的，真的就像是，我不会说的，对吧？不，我不会谈论这件事的。他说，绅士们，接吻了可不能到处宣扬，我也不。哈哈哈哈。你知道，然后接下来我们知道的，他就变成，我们必须披露，我们必须写一封信。是的。
That's so true. About our relationship. He just, oh man. In that talking head, I love the camera work in that. It's a very, very slow push in on Michael's face and you can just feel the camera putting all this pressure on Michael to tell the truth. How long does he last?
太真实了。关于我们的关系。他简直，哦天哪。在那段面对镜头的独白中，我太喜欢那里的运镜了。那是对迈克尔脸部的一个非常非常缓慢的推镜头，你甚至能感觉到镜头给迈克尔施加了所有的压力，逼他说出真相。他能坚持多久？
He lasts like 14 seconds. Seconds, seconds. He's like, all right, fine. We went back and we- To her hotel and we made out for a little bit. I held her and she talked to me about her divorce. Oh my gosh. That phone call with Jan where he goes under the desk, Greg directed that.
他大概坚持了14秒。秒，秒。他说，好吧，行。我们回到了——去她的酒店，然后亲热了一会儿。我抱了她，她跟我聊了她的离婚。哦天哪。他和简通电话时躲在桌子底下的那一幕，是格雷格导演的。
Greg told Steve, why don't you take this phone call under the desk to avoid the camera crew? And he said it was great because they were able to edit together all of Steve's improvisations because you can't see his mouth. Oh, so smart. Yeah, because Steve was improvising a lot of that phone call and the things that he was saying back to Jan. Then we have Jim and Pam's, kind of their first fight. I don't know. I mean, they have that hiccup at the dojo, but this is different. They have little moments. I mean, they have that hiccup at the dojo, but this is different. They have little moments. I mean, he got his feelings really hurt
格雷格告诉史蒂夫，你为什么不躲到桌子底下打这通电话以避开摄像组呢？他说这太棒了，因为他们能够把史蒂夫所有的即兴发挥剪辑到一起，因为你看不到他的嘴。哦，太聪明了。对，因为史蒂夫在那通电话里即兴发挥了很多内容，还有他回复简的话。然后是吉姆和帕姆的，某种程度上他们的第一次争吵。我不懂。我是说，他们在道场有过一次小摩擦，但这不一样。他们有过一些短暂的时刻。我是说，他们在道场有过一次小摩擦，但这不一样。他们有过一些短暂的时刻。我是说，他的感情真的受到了伤害
when you suggested he try, you know, go for that job at the other branch. Like, and then there was the dojo and now there's this. Well, this one doesn't get resolved at the end of this episode. Jim suggests to Pam that maybe they had their first date, that you could say this was their first date. And I want to say something. suggests to Pam that maybe they had their first date, that you could say this was their first date.
当你建议他去试试，你知道的，去争取另一个分部的那个工作时。就像，然后是道场，现在又是这个。好吧，这一集结束时并没有解决这个问题。吉姆向帕姆暗示也许他们有过第一次约会，你可以说这就是他们的第一次约会。我想说点什么。向帕姆暗示也许他们有过第一次约会，你可以说这就是他们的第一次约会。
And I want to say something. I understand why Pam bristles at this. Well, let me just take a minute. First of all, Pam lies to Roy, bold face lies to Roy and says, I have to stay at work. And he's like, are you kidding me right now? And she's like, no, I have to work. So already, like she has probably within her moral compass, stepped over a line.
我想说点什么。我理解为什么帕姆对这种说法感到生气。好吧，让我花一分钟时间。首先，帕姆对罗伊撒谎了，睁眼说瞎话地对罗伊说，我得留在公司加班。然后罗伊的反应就像是，你现在是在逗我吗？她却说，不，我得工作。所以其实她已经在她的道德底线边缘，越过了一条线。
I think for Jim, now look guys, I'm a huge Jim and Pam fan, and I wanted them together from the beginning. But I would think as a guy, I was talking to my husband about this, and he goes, this is kind of a move Jim's doing. He knows she has a fiance, but he makes a has a fiance,
我觉得对吉姆来说，听着伙计们，我是吉姆和帕姆的超级粉丝，我从一开始就希望他们在一起。但我觉得作为一个男人，我和我丈夫谈过这个，他说，吉姆这招挺有一套的。他知道她有未婚夫，但他还是做了一个有未婚夫，
but he makes a grilled cheese sandwich, takes her up on the roof. Like he knows, this is his moment. He's going for it. Ultimately they end up together, so it's great. But that's not, that kind of breaks guy code of what you do with someone else's fiance. Well, and then I think for him to call it out so clearly
但他还是做了一个烤奶酪三明治，带她上了屋顶。就像他知道的，这是他的时刻。他要主动出击了。最终他们走到了一起，所以这很好。但那不是，那有点打破了跟别人未婚夫交往的男人守则。好吧，然后我觉得他当着那么多人的面
out in the open, I think Pam is willing to pretend like none of that is happening and they're just friends while it's happening. But for you to just look at her and say, Hey, you were kind of unfaithful last night was very shocking for her. And she had to shut that down. She had to be like, I'm sorry, I don't know what you're talking about. You're just my friend and we were hanging out after work so, I don't know what you thought that was but uncool Right. That was her way of trying to get her boundary back and also just being defensive knowing that she did something she shouldn't have
公开这么说出来，我觉得帕姆宁愿假装这一切都没有发生，在事情发生时他们只是普通朋友。但你却直接看着她说，嘿，你昨晚有点不忠哦，这让她感到非常震惊。她不得不拒绝承认。她不得不说，抱歉，我不知道你在说什么。你只是我的朋友，我们只是下班后一起闲逛，所以，我不知道你觉得那是什么，但这太不酷了。没错，那是她试图重新划清界限的方式，同时也是出于防备，因为她知道自己做了不该做的事。
I think well I think whenever like there's a moment when Angela catches her with Pam Pong, then Meredith catches the shirt coming up, right? And then this moment when he calls it out, all of those moments are when Pam gets a mirror held up to her behavior, and it makes her uncomfortable because she knows the right thing to do is say, Roy, I'm in love with Jim, and we should break up. But she's got all of these layers like you do in a relationship and feelings probably of guilt
我觉得，每当有安吉拉撞见她跟帕姆打乒乓球的时刻，然后梅丽迪斯撞见衣服掀起来的时刻，对吧？然后是当他直言不讳的这个时刻，所有这些时刻都是帕姆的一面镜子映照出她自己的行为，这让她感到不舒服，因为她知道正确做法应该是说，罗伊，我爱吉姆，我们应该分手。但她背负着所有的层层包袱，就像你在恋爱中所做的那样，可能还有内疚感
and obligation and all of that all wrapped up into it. So she doesn't know how to make that break. And I think this is one of those moments where a mirror is held up and she feels bad and she bristles at it. And then it all ends with that final look between Michael and Jim, the little shrug. Eh, women. Ah, what are you gonna do?
和责任感，所有这些都交织在一起。所以她不知道该如何做个了断。我觉得这就是那种照出镜子并让她感到糟糕、让她感到生气的时刻。然后这一切以迈克尔和吉姆之间的最后一个眼神结束，一个轻微的耸肩。唉，女人啊。啊，你还能怎么办？
Yeah. Two lonely guys. Well, guys, that was The Client. That's The Client. Thank you so much, Melora Hardin and Tim Meadows, for making this episode that much more special. And I want to say thank you to Brian Baumgartner and Phil Shea and Greg Daniels, all of whom I reached out to
对。两个孤独的家伙。好吧，伙计们，这就是《客户》。这就是《客户》。非常感谢梅洛拉·哈丁和蒂姆·梅多斯，让这一集变得更加特别。我也想感谢布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳、菲尔·谢伊和格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他们都是我联系过的
for this episode. Thanks, guys, for your help. Thanks everybody. All right, we'll see you next week. We're gonna be chunking performance review your way. Oh boy. Oh boy. Hey, I'm proud of us for pulling it back together.
为了这一集。谢谢你们，谢谢你们的帮忙。谢谢大家。好的，我们下周见。我们将为大家带来《绩效考核》。哦天哪。哦天哪。嘿，我为我们重新振作起来感到骄傲。
We were really on the edge at the beginning of this one. I got a little giddy. I have a little punchy. So thanks for sticking it out. That's what she said. Good ending. Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf.
这一集刚开始时我们真的快崩了。我有点情绪高涨。我有点语无伦次。所以谢谢你们坚持听完。这就是她说的。很好的结尾。谢谢。感谢收听“办公室辣妈第二杯”。本期节目最初与Earwulf合作制作。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室辣妈》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的一档节目，由珍娜·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师兼副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。本期节目由克里斯·巴塞尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。